we once used to judge people mostly
based on their deeds but in the age of
social media we judge people mostly
based on their opinions and since we're
now defined by our opinions there is
pressure to have an opinion on
everything problem is is that people
generally don't have the time or the
will to research every issue on which
they're expected to have an opinion so
they copy the opinions of others and the
result of this is that there are
preciously few genuine thinkers out
there the majority of people posting
opinions online are just thoughtlessly
reposting other people's opinions as
their own
so as is tradition you write these huge
threads on twitter i fall in love with
all of the concepts and then we get to
go through them but before we start on
some of the concepts you put a tweet out
about the uh pandering and posturing
that companies are doing in the west
versus what they're doing in the middle
east what did you learn there
yeah so i mean
uh you know i thought it was quite
interesting because
uh you can tell whether a belief is
genuine by what people are willing to
sacrifice for it
and
corporations love to appear
compassionate by claiming to stand for
black lives matter or gay pride or
trance rights
but they only openly support these
rights in countries in which they're
already popular
they're not willing to
risk or sacrifice anything for their
professed beliefs and the reason for
this is that their beliefs are just a
charade
um so really the point here is just that
words are cheap you know so
if you really want to know if a person's
principles are genuine
see what it actually costs them if it's
cost them something then it's probably a
genuine belief but if it's cost them
nothing
then it's just noise
and we see a lot of that today you know
in this kind of
image-oriented age in which we live um
where corporations feel the need to be
part of the conversation and they're
constantly putting out these opinions
that they think are going to be popular
but it's all just it's just a show you
know so i just wanted to draw attention
to that
we see
so much june 1st is like the um twitter
up profile
update photo
collage
deployment
waterfall thing where cisco mercedes
lenovo bmw bethesda
visa bp and millions others that we
probably haven't got screenshots of have
decided to have their
central account with the colors of the
rainbow we're supporting pride we're in
support of gay people around the world
and then the middle east version hasn't
been updated at all i was trying to come
up with a name for it and i was thinking
of something like equality shadow boxing
because that's kind of like what they're
doing
yeah they're fighting in a an arena that
where the
concept's already been won corporations
support pride in the west where it's
widely accepted but not in the east
because their activism is not motivated
by principles but by public relations so
fighting where the battle has already
been won and not fighting for equality
where it's needed
yes absolutely i mean if i had to use a
word to describe it i would just call it
pandering um really you know a nice
simple word because that's essentially
what it is they're they're looking at
their target audience and they're saying
what does this audience want and
at the moment corporations really want
to pull in the sort of tick-tock teens
because they want to get people when
they're young they want to establish you
know brand loyalty to these kids when
they're young so that they'll sort of
stay with them for life and so
um
the tick tock generation is kind of
quite infamous for being quite woke and
you know into all this kind of like uh
sort of social justice posturing
and
as a result of that i think that's why
they've chosen this route they've chosen
to go
towards the more kind of you know social
justice kind of thing you don't really
see corporations sort of being based you
know being you know sort of pro sort of
trump or whatever you know i mean you've
got elon musk who's a very rare
exception he's kind of gone towards the
base group
but i think
he i think he that's him as an
individual tesla is not doing that you
know tesla is sort of quite still quite
on the left sort of
probably desperately trying to hold on
to whatever uh acceptable face that they
can and wrangling working their way kind
of around elon is this he's a bit of a
force to be reckoned with on his own but
yeah i mean we see this with um body
positivity
websites that are using plus sized girls
and some use plus size guys but for the
most part you don't ever see skinny fat
guys right that are pale that look like
they spend a ton of time in vr okay so
it's it's not about bodies of all sizes
and making everybody feel represented
it's about pushing a narrative that
drives more clicks and means that you
can say we are part of the virtuous
crowd you do not need to look here over
there those are the people that aren't
doing it uh i mean you see it with the
the different races that are used as
well a lot of them i mean asos is really
bad for this tons and tons of their
models are now mixed race guys that have
got neck tattoos but there's no asians
there's basically no asians on that site
and you go okay like
what is it that you're doing it's it's
split testing something that
mediates between
we need to be able to show variety and
signal virtue and we still need to drive
clicks so all of that's been split
tested as well if fat asian lads
were selling more asos clothes do you
not think that they would be using it um
exactly yeah
i mean you know i don't see a problem
with sort of
diversifying sort of models and things
like that i think it's okay but i think
the issue
begins when
there's when it's basically sort of done
performatively and an example of this is
um in i think there's this i don't
really watch star wars so i don't know
much about it but i saw this tweet
recently
um in which the star wars official
account
basically posted their new actress who's
going to be like a main star of one of
their upcoming shows or something i
don't i don't really know what it is but
it was a black woman and the tweet was
essentially saying like this is our new
um star she's a black woman she's a
strong independent black woman and they
were really like highlighting the fact
that she's black you know and they were
like you know if you have a problem with
her then we don't want you um to be one
of our fans you know it was a very sort
of confrontational tweet and i was like
i don't understand the point in it
because if you look at the previous the
old star wars i mean i haven't really
seen much but i remember the originals
and there's that lando calrissian is a
black guy there's no mention is made of
this guy being a black guy because he
doesn't it doesn't need to be made the
point doesn't need to be made that he's
a black guy he you know it doesn't
matter that he's a black guy so
people didn't have a problem with that
and it's when they start
forcefully saying you know this is our
main star and this is a black guy or a
black woman and you you you will enjoy
it or you will you know suffer the
consequences sort of thing yeah that's i
think that's it's a very aggressive kind
of
thing that i think a lot turns a lot of
people off but also it also turns a lot
of people on unfortunately as well which
is why they do it
if we make it all the way to whatever
your star wars is set in and we've got
lightsabers and laser guns and we can
travel super super fast around the
universe and yet still the most
important thing about somebody is their
skin color i honestly think just bring
on the death star man [ __ ] send us
all send us all to the ends of hell
because
i don't want to live in that future yeah
absolutely terrible we are
okay so moving on to your concept from
this new super tweet thread which will
be linked in the show notes below if
people want to go and check that out uh
bonhoeffer's theory of stupidity evil
can be guarded against stupidity cannot
and the world's few evil people have
little power without the help of the
world's many stupid people as a result
stupidity is a far greater threat than
evil
yeah
so
so we have a tendency as a species to
view the world in monitian terms
monition is a fancy word of saying that
we divide the world into good and evil
um
we evolved to view our tribe as good and
the enemy tribe is evil to justify
annihilating them quite frankly
uh and taking their resources without
any sort of hesitation or guilt or you
know any sort of other
emotion that might get in the way
um
tribes that were sort of morally
relativists
they would not have survived for very
long
because they would have been killed by
the tribes that were morally absolutist
the ones that were so sure that they
were right and their enemies were evil
so as a result of that we have this kind
of
flaw in our dna which is that we see the
world in municipal terms we tend to
divide
things into good and evil we see
struggles as fairy tales in a way
it means that when you have a debate
with somebody online on twitter
you're instead of sort of seeing them as
just having a disagreement you'll see
them as evil often times you know
um
you know you can see it today with the
way that the left sort of views the
right as bigots
and increasingly you see the right
viewing the left as groomers and child
abusers and you know so
they they take the worst sort of thing
that they can think of and they
attribute that to their the people that
they disagree with this is sort of an
evolutionary sort of byproduct that we
have
um i think
if we recognize that
most people are just merely ignorant
rather than actually being malevolent
then disagreement ceases to become a
cause of conflict
and it instead becomes an opportunity
for understanding
so i think that that's a crucial lesson
for social media in particular
how is it that stupidity can't be
guarded against and how is it that
stupid people help evil people
well because
stupidity is not predictable
you know it's not you can't predict when
you're going to make a mistake whereas
you can to extend predict
what an evil person is going to do
an evil person will try to do evil you
know but stupidity is so broad and it's
you can make so many mistakes at so many
different points of reasoning that you
just
it's impossible to predict so you can't
really guard against it
um so
you know that's
that's that's
the first thing and then the second
thing
is that
there are some evil people i mean i use
the word evil broadly to describe people
who are sadists people who take pleasure
in the suffering of others or either
that or people who are sort of
sociopaths and people who don't care at
all about other people's feelings have
zero you know regard for them
um
but these people are a tiny minority you
know most people are not like that
and
what these people do these psychopaths
and these sociopaths
um is that they can't really do it much
on their own i mean they can become
serial killers and they do sometimes but
a serial killer can usually only kill a
few dozen people at most before they're
caught
whereas
if you look at the most destructive
people in history
they were people who had armies they had
people who had nations behind them
and these people were essentially they
were psychopaths to an extent
um
you know people like stalin and hitler
for instance they had very
sort of uh a low regard for human life
but they were only able to do what they
did because they were able to get many
many many stupid people onto their side
you know and not even necessarily stupid
people but just people who are
uninformed basically
and it's so it's really
if they didn't have all of those people
on their side then they wouldn't have
done they wouldn't have been able to get
anywhere close to what they did
they would have probably you know it
might have just ended up being a crappy
artist you know like he was going to be
before he was chucked out of art school
um stalin would probably have become a
priest because he was you know a
seminary when he was young so
it's
these
it's the masses the sort of the stupid
masses who really caused them the
destruction in the end it's not the the
people that we we
put all the blame on
they're just the sort of spark that
ignites the wildfire
as it were next one mean world syndrome
the news exists to get your attention so
it tends to shock as such it doesn't
reflect reality but precisely that which
is uncharacteristic of reality but since
it's all we see we begin to think the
world is crazier than it actually is
yeah so
so people want to see stuff that's
surprising um because it has more
informational value
you learn more from what's surprising
than what from what's mundane and
predictable
and since people have an appetite for
the surprising
the information filters that dictate
what you see online the editorial
filters the algorithmic filters
they select for shocking stuff basically
so the news that you see
is stuff that's intended
to sort of shock you
and obviously if it's shocking you then
it's not going to be characteristic of
reality it's not going to be something
that you could predict
it's going to be something that's
completely out of the ordinary
the problem is is that while your mind
is
browsing this information online
it's not very good at critical thinking
because you enter something called a
dissociative state in which you kind of
zone into what you're looking at and you
kind of become lost and then you don't
you lose the capacity for thought and as
a result of that
what happens is that you
lose the ability to make the distinction
between
what you're seeing and the probability
of it actually occurring so
you see
extraordinary events and you regard them
as just ordinary events in a sense
when you see them enough times
so
the problem with this is that
it it leads us to sort of see
things like injustices and other sort of
uh anomalies
as the norm
and we'll probably
get more into this actually with some of
my other concepts but yeah i mean
so it's a yeah this is i think a very
important concept for um
again for social media because when you
have a curated feed
like twitter
you're seeing information that has
passed through several filters and that
information
every time it passes through a filter it
selects for stuff that's
uncharacteristic of reality so it's
taking you further and further away from
reality as it passes through all these
various filters the you know the
algorithms and the sort of editorial
decisions and all that sort of stuff and
your own decisions as well
so i think it's it's one that people
should be aware of definitely because it
it's strange about what rises to the top
you know the most shocking news stories
the ones that are unrepresentative the
ones that are uncharacteristic of what
happens they're the ones that garner the
most attention they're the ones that
limbically hijack so they're the ones
that are going to be pushed the most
online by other people and by the
algorithm and then
it's so obvious when you think well
the reason that people are shocked by it
is the fact that it wasn't mundane but
by definition of it being shocking and
not mundane it has to be an outlier
event
and if you get a collection of outlier
events all the time because that's
what's most effective in order to garner
the most attention on the internet and
on news
what you have is a selection of
anomalies put together to try and
represent a world that people think well
this is just what happens and
i also think
the human brain is not meant to consume
the entire globe's news
in real time
24 hours a day and then when you have
some perverse incentives like this going
on as well what you end up with is a
very sort of skewed perspective of just
what's going on
it doesn't surprise me that people think
that the world's going to [ __ ] at the
moment you know it's chaos out there
the world's never been so turbulent and
well has it or is that just the lens
through which the information that
you're being fed is giving it because
think about your daily experience it's
strange that people can hold in their
minds at the same time um
the world is kind of banal and it's this
sort of gray sludge that we're being fed
to kind of keep us working for the man
and yet at the same time it's a
post-apocalyptic hellscape with you know
fire and brimstone going on outside yeah
people's personal experience doesn't
seem to match up
with what's going on this is the same
with the black pill mgtow in cell
movement too that
most guys when you actually drill down
and say look what's your experience like
with women
it's perfectly pleasant
most guys that's not to say that there
isn't a bunch of amber herds out there
that are manipulative and and doing
stuff to to men and taking the kids away
from them and accusing them of stuff
yeah
but for the most part and yet because
the internet and reddit forums and
telegram groups and
youtube channels that work in that space
obviously raise up the most shocking
stories out of the lot well what do you
end up with you end up with a group of
people that believe that those stories
are representative of what all women are
like whilst having an experience in
their own life which completely
disproves that yeah
yeah i mean you know it gives people a
completely distorted sense of reality
and it's one reason why i've actually
sort of toned down my consumption of
news because um
i mean i read this really good piece by
uh i don't know if you know sarah hyder
she's a a writer yeah writes on sub
stack and she wrote a great piece about
news consumption about what it's
actually good for and
you know she sort of came to the
conclusion that
essentially most of the news that we
consume is actually pointless it doesn't
help us in our daily lives it doesn't
really
enlighten us it doesn't make us it
doesn't increase our understanding of
the world
and when you pair it with what we're
talking about in fact it actually has
the opposite effect it makes you less
informed because it distorts your sense
of reality
and so i what i do now i mean i still
have to consume better news because
obviously i'm a writer so i have to
write about what's going on in the world
but
i only consume what i have to i don't
consume any more than that
i feel that if you get into a habit of
like feeling that you always have to
keep up with what's going on
it puts you in this kind of trap in
which you're you're sort of just
constantly distorting your own reality
every day every time you log on you know
in the morning and you check twitter or
whatever you're
you're creating a sort of false
narrative in your mind
which
it compounds with itself over time if
you the more you consume news the more
distorted your reality becomes and so i
think really
the best way out of this is just to
limit your consumption of news to
to basically what is
essential for you to know and and to not
really bother with all the other stuff
because it really doesn't help
i am in a group chat with a bunch of
guys from austin and one of them came up
with something that i think should be in
should appear in one of your future
tweet threads so i'm going to give it to
you now it's the midwit appeal theorem
by definition most people are midwits
therefore nothing can achieve mass
significance without appealing to and
allowing itself to be explained by
midwitz
it's something that you know uh
something else that i've written about
is the idea that we all tend to sort of
converge in our narratives because
we all ultimately see the stuff that
gets the most traction online
and this is what results in midwit's
midwifes are people who browse the
internet in in predictable ways and
because they're browsing the internet
predictable ways uh it's very easy
to game them
you know social media can game them very
easily so it can um show them stuff
that's gonna sort of incite outrage or
whatever because it knows that they're
predictable so it can it can sort of it
knows what they're going to see it knows
what they're not going to see
and when you've got large numbers of
people all consuming the same content
the result is that people tend to sort
of form these big blocks of like-minded
not not just like-minded but people of
uniform beliefs
you know and uh and that's where the
midwifes come from i think they're all
people who just consume
the internet in very predictable ways
which is why i try to do the opposite i
try to you know
look at things that other people are not
looking at um click on the 21st search
result rather than the first you know
that kind of stuff um fooling the
algorithm i think is very important to
maintain a kind of independent mindset
or just being really stupid all being
really really smart but it's kind of
hard pretty hard to be really really
smart but yeah just be really stupid or
really smart is the best way to
inoculate yourself right next one next
one from you uh two-step flow theory
most people's opinions are copied from
their favorite influencers who in turn
copy the opinions of their favored mass
media as such politics is largely a
battle between two armies of puppets
being ventriloquized by a handful of
actual thinkers
yeah
so this is
um one of my sort of pet issues um
so basically the the rise of social
media as the primary form of social
interaction
changed the way that we evaluate people
uh we once used to judge people mostly
based on their deeds
but in the age of social media we judge
people mostly based on their opinions
because that's really all we see of
people
and since we're now defined by our
opinions there is pressure to have an
opinion on everything
the problem is is that people generally
don't
have the time or the will to research
every issue on which they're expected to
have an opinion
so they copy the opinions of others
and the result of this is that there are
preciously few genuine thinkers out
there basically the the majority of
people posting opinions online are just
thoughtlessly reposting other people's
opinions
as their own
what this means is that almost everyone
who posts an opinion online has not
actually researched it
or even considered it you know they
don't actually consider the issue that
they are pointing on
so in other words you know they don't
know what they're talking about where do
you think the first mover of this comes
from because it has to be someone that
comes up with something somewhere yeah
yeah i mean there are people out there
who come up with ideas you know the
intellectuals
they're a very very sort of small
minority of people but there are genuine
thinkers
and
what happens is that these guys come up
with the ideas
uh and gals they come out with the ideas
and
then everybody just copies them
and then they get copied and then they
get copied so what usually happens is
there are a few people usually in the
mainstream media commentators
and they have original thoughts and then
influencers will usually read these
and then they'll sort of just
just basically parrot them yeah just
parrot them
and then the people who follow those
influences will parrot them and then it
just spreads like a virus basically you
know do you remember in the general
election the uk general election was
that 2019 the last one yeah and in the
lead up to that if you watched social
media you would have thought this is an
absolute whitewash for labor
and you were seeing
stormzy
and amber that won love island and all
of these people that were like so
vehement and you think well this
person's got a very very strong opinion
and they're just one person so the other
people they
must be a complete army that's behind
them and then the results came in and
you realize that yeah it was just
loud people saying things that they
definitely i mean
forgive me but
stormzy doesn't strike me as the sort of
guy that's spent ages considering his
political position makes good music but
like he's not absolutely political
thinker i mean
i i think the thing with storms is that
his crowd
are not really political they're not
really interested in voting in elections
and that's where the mistake was made
because
although yeah there are probably a lot
of people who who voted because of him
it was nowhere near the amount that
people expected simply because he's not
he's not generally a political figure
he's an artist
and people are more interested in his
music than they are in his opinions
uh really i think where the two-step
flow theory really sort of
becomes apparent i think is on social
media with
uh things like sort of pl political
opinions you know that actually sort of
spread through social media in
particular amongst the political classes
not amongst sort of
teens you know because i mean stormzy's
main audience are probably teens aren't
they i mean
um those guys are not political really
so
yeah it's it's mainly this is more of an
issue that really sort of becomes
apparent on
on in twitter politics well if you think
about what a retweet actually is
what is a retweet it's you
it is a demonstration of that very fact
it is actually parroting an opinion
precisely learning an opinion yeah um so
yeah i mean yeah exactly that's a very
good point yeah it's
it's sort of so it works in two ways i
think
firstly
people copy opinions directly but then
secondly
they also would rather just retweet
something rather than actually think for
themselves it's much easier just to
press the retweet button then formulate
your own tweet
i do think
the the retweet function
the less that you use it most of the
accounts that i follow don't retweet
that much i think that they're the
they're closer to the first movers and
that's probably a pretty good heuristic
like are most of the people that you
follow retweeting or are most of them
either quote tweeting or tweeting their
own stuff because even if they've even
if they've reworded something that
sounds smart at least i mean that's one
degree of separation or half a degree of
separation yeah absolutely because if
you reword something you have to
actually consider it in your mind you
have to you have to sort of pass it and
then once you've passed it you've got to
rearrange it and that requires thought
so that's actually a pretty good thing
to do in fact that's a good way to learn
i think is to actually take an opinion
and then deconstruct it
and to rearrange it and you can actually
then i mean i've done that with some
people's things because i remember
reading this thing about how to become a
better writer when i was younger and
it said you should take
sort of a page of a writer that you
really admire and you should rewrite
what they've written in your own words
and i found that that's a really good
exercise just to sort of because you
pick up on things when you're rewriting
it that you don't when you're just
reading it holes in your understanding
and yeah you're actually interacting
with the text rather than just passively
you know consuming it
and so i i would encourage that i think
that's a very good thing to do
introspection illusion
we think we understand the real reasons
why we think and act the way we do but
we think other people have little
understanding of why they think and act
the way they do we assess ourselves as
if they're psychiatric patients and
ourselves as if we're gods
yeah
so
i mean you've probably noticed this when
you've sort of witnessed a twitter
debate
but many debates online
consists not of two people trying to
refute
each other's ideas but rather two people
trying to psycho analyze each other
um so for example you know
i believe what i believe because it
makes sense you believe what you believe
because you're just seeking social
approval
and you know i do think many people
believe things just for social approval
like we were just
talking about you know with the
corporations earlier
but
it's much harder for me to accuse myself
of seeking social approval you know
it's something i haven't really it's a
bit alien to me i think it's alien to
everybody to accuse themselves
of
believing something for something other
than reason it's not something that we
normally do
um
i mean you know i don't think i do
believe things for social approval but
i can't be sure because my actual
motivations could just be
rationalizations
so you know this is it it basically puts
you in a bit of a tricky spot where you
have to really consider the things that
you're accusing other people of
isn't it strange that you never accuse
yourself of these very things
so i think we should sense a foster of
cons we should foster a sense of
consistency on this issue
um
you know yes many people hold beliefs as
a result of social needs and character
flaws so it's legitimate to accuse of
the people of it but for the very same
reason we should recognize that we could
also be guilty of it and therefore
instead of getting defensive we should
be open to accusations that we believe
what we believe due to character flaws
rather than reason
this is the fundamental attribution
error as well right yeah yeah to an
extent yeah that i mean that's more to
do with whether you believe something
because of an inherent
something inherent to you or whether you
believe something due to situational
factors
so yeah it's i think the the fundamental
attribution error is is a more broader
way of yes
i'm saying this yeah yeah but the it is
this is something that i always said to
people that are going through uh
breakups if you invert this
what you realize is
your understanding of yourself and the
depth of time and detail that you've
gone into your own mind with is greater
than
even if you had a conjoined twin
you're going to have with them so if
somebody's gone through a breakup a lot
of the time and it wasn't their choice
they romanticize the other partner they
make them out to be kind of saintly and
they're wistfully just sort of chasing
after them
and they can also put them on a pedestal
it's gonna be very difficult to find
somebody like this so on and so forth
but one of the ways that you can at
least invert that a little bit is by
using this introspection illusion kind
of to your advantage and think well look
at how deep and rich
your understanding of your experience
experiences right there is this wild
asymmetry basically your your brain's
infinite to you and somebody else is
unbelievably finite to you in your
experience not only do you not know what
they're thinking
all that you know about what they're
thinking is what they've communicated to
you and they can communicate what they
do what they think at a much lower
bandwidth than they think and they don't
choose to say everything and you weren't
there for all of the things that they
were going to say so this asymmetry
between the two i think is something
that
can cause people firstly to feel quite
lonely in the world right because your
inner experience is significantly richer
than the reflected experience you get
from other people but on top of that as
well
it is something that should make you
feel a bit reassured that you are you
are special because
your experience of you is the only
person the only consciousness that's
ever going to get that degree of depth
so it is the sort of thing
i think in part that
should give people uh reason to be sort
of proud of themselves
yeah absolutely
yeah
um
i think
it's always worthwhile to sort of
consider
oneself like when one is when one's sort
of forming opinions to actually consider
what one gains from it or what one would
lose from it because
i think um
you know the idea is that we don't
really know ourselves we don't know
ourselves we think we know ourselves you
know we have this idea of who we are
but
really
that's
we can't step outside of ourselves we
know we're stuck inside of ourselves and
that prevents us from seeing the forest
for the trees so to speak so really we
can't we can't really second-guess our
own opinions we can't know the real
reasons why we believe what we believe
but what we can do is we can try to
understand what we would gain from those
beliefs
you know so if i if i have a political
belief i should ask myself
what would i actually gain from
believing this because
we know now that you know a lot of
beliefs are not just sort of reason uh
they're not just a result of reason
they there's complex factors that play
in a tim in terms of somebody's
character and what they want from life
and you know people believe things
because they think it brings them
comfort or you know there's so many
different factors to what goes into a
belief
so
in order to avoid the trap of believing
something purely
for an irrational reason it's always
worth asking you what else you stand to
gain from that belief
it's something that i've been trying to
do it's a very hard habit to develop
because we're used to criticizing other
people for that you know we're not used
to doing it to ourselves but i think
when you do it to yourself it really
does help you understand yourself it
helps you understand why
you think the way that you do you know
if you look at your experiences and you
try to understand how your experiences
have shaped your beliefs if you can make
a habit of that then you can start to
interrogate yourself and start to
realize why you believe what you believe
and to sort of see the flaws in your own
beliefs and then correct them
would you say that if somebody assesses
either one of their own beliefs or that
of somebody else and it seems like they
pay quite a high price for holding that
belief that they should probably
consider that as more
likely to be truthful
i always think about this with regards
to sam harris that the fact that he's
got
um he was
anti-woke but anti-trump he was pro-vaxx
but uh anti-mask mandate you know he
held a very sort of unusual
um dynamic in his beliefs and you go
well he's paying a high price for that
does that mean i probably tend to have a
bit more faith that he actually believes
what he believes absolutely i mean yeah
like we were saying earlier you know
with the corporations you know not
risking anything with for their beliefs
when you risk something with your
beliefs or when you sacrifice something
for your beliefs then that's a sign that
your beliefs are genuine but that
doesn't mean that your beliefs
are justified
you know that's a whole different
ballgame and i think the introspection
illusion is really more about
establishing whether your beliefs are
justified rather than whether they're
genuinely held because you can make a
good idea you have a good idea of
whether your beliefs are genuinely held
you know better than anyone whether your
beliefs are genuinely held but you you
can't really tell whether your beliefs
are justified until you interrogate
yourself
and that takes a lot of effort it's
something that is completely alien to
human beings
yeah all right sayer's law the lower the
stakes the more vicious the politics
intense nuclear talks people act
civilized in twitter culture wars people
act like armageddon has come raging like
maniacs calling for total war safe in
the knowledge that none of it matters
yeah so um this law was originally
invented to describe academic politics
but it's recently become applicable to
online politics
um ser didn't really offer an
explanation for the law
but i think i have one of my own
which is
basically firstly people
people's egos cause them to exaggerate
the importance of their struggles
when it's possible to do so
in truly serious matters understanding
is essential
therefore precision of language is
essential this prevents people from
exaggerating
their struggles
but when it comes to issues with lower
stakes
in which there is some leeway
accurately describing reality becomes
less important so people could take
greater liberties to exaggerate their
pet issue so
the result
you can see it widely in in the culture
wars so for instance you know um
with the woke left sort of thing words
of violence silence is violence
you know um using the wrong pronoun and
is erasing someone's existence
uh dressing as a cherokee for halloween
is committing genocide against native
americans you know
um but i mean
it we do see this problem on the right
also it's not just the problem of the
left i mean for instance
um you know uh racial mixing is white
genocide you know
so both sides engage in this kind of um
you know sort of
catastrophization
and i think really
it's it's just a symptom of people
wanting their struggles to seem more
important than they actually are
because
really it's they're not that important
when you when you really consider
you know the grand scheme of things and
so people make up for it whereas when
people actually do have real struggles
they have to be truthful they have to be
precise
because there are costs to being
incorrect or imprecise
so the result is that
you can gauge how serious an issue is by
the language used to describe it
issues that are described in
sensationalist terms are generally not
as serious as issues that are described
in very precise terms
because in the latter case the rewards
for misrepresenting reality are smaller
and the risks are far greater
what was sayer trying to describe
originally
so he was trying to describe academic
politics as
this kind of thing very bitter and very
vicious struggle where people are very
petty and
i mean you could say that he was talking
about the narcissism of small
differences
um you know he was basically saying that
because the stakes are so low in
politics people's egos generally drive
them to become more ruthless and more
petty basically just just to sort of
compensate for the fact that their
struggles are so trivial
but he didn't like i said he didn't
really explain it he just it was more of
an observation and i really had to think
about it to try and work out why i
thought it was true
and i think i mean i do believe it is
true it's just that it took me a while
to try and work out why and i think that
that's what it is i think
that there are costs
to being untruthful when the stakes are
high when when you're in a nuclear
negotiation you can't misrepresent
reality you have to be truthful because
the cost is too great and the rewards
are small because you don't need to
exaggerate the problem because the
problem's already big
whereas when you're in a small struggle
like a twitter culture war
there's plenty of room to be untruthful
because it doesn't matter because it's
so it's so trivial
it doesn't matter whether you're
economical with the truth you can just
say whatever it doesn't matter it's all
inconsequential so people exaggerate and
they they laugh and they catastrophize
and
then they just you know the result is
that this problem takes on an
apocalyptic tone even though it's
usually just
just what somebody said online you know
and bizarrely there's probably an
inversion between the seriousness of the
problem the language that's used to
describe it which means that the
problems that probably require the most
attention are the ones that
linguistically are given perhaps not the
least but they're at least being
constrained with precision uh
thoughtfulness
uh and perhaps even in some situations i
suppose
like secrecy to degree you know
so many there's this uh it's called
terrorism close calls
and it's on netflix it's kind of a bit
cheesy actually it could have it could
have been much better but it's kind of
fun um and it's
declassified files and cia agents and
stuff and fbi people that have dealt
with close calls where some serious [ __ ]
nearly went down and
this is how you're finding out about it
this is it's 30 years ago and someone
was going to blow up a tube going from
new york to
whatever long island or some [ __ ] that's
how you found out about it yeah
and i wonder as well whether
again everything
it's easy to bring everything back to
social media because almost everything
is mediated by social media and the
perverse incentives that you have online
for attracting attention for using this
inflammatory language it's kind of
really hard to just separate that out
and go okay this is this is just
something like gravity that's always
there how do we then pass this in but
for sure this is a big reason that it
gets promulgated even more the fact that
signaling is such a big part of what you
do now online and that the language that
you use is one of the primary signals
that you use
yeah absolutely yeah
yeah i mean um i think really the
twitter culture war is largely a result
of
language being used to exaggerate um
struggles you know uh it's it's taken on
this kind of apocalyptic tone precisely
because
of the way that it's described you know
online but when you really break it down
what what actually is it it's just
people
sneering at each other online it's just
you know it's just kind of people
exchanging insults that's all it is
because although the struggle you know
some of the struggles might be real like
for instance
you know things like uh
transgender rights and things these are
all real political struggles but the
actual twitter culture war is divorced
from that even though it it purports to
be about such things it doesn't really
have any effect on these on these issues
it seems as well like it's kind of a bit
of a losing battle because let's say
that there is a serious problem that
you're dealing with uh so you decide to
use precise language and treat it with
the requisite respect that it deserves
it doesn't garner any attention then you
decide okay well that's not going to
work so we'll try the flamboyant
incendiary language instead and then
people have got this filter i have this
filter even if it's subconscious until i
read this thread and realized why
i'll discount that so okay so you're
damned if you do and you're damned if
people aren't going to pay attention if
you're precise and realistic with your
language and they're going to castigate
you and dismiss it if you're
inflammatory with your language so yeah
i think
a big rule over the top of all of this
is social media is a very bad way to
have conversations that are serious yes
yeah absolutely yeah
next one let's go on to nut-picking
cherry-picking the most outlandish
members of the enemy side and presenting
them as indicative in order to make the
entire side look crazy a common tactic
on twitter arguably the entire culture
war is just each side sneering at the
other side's lunatics that
is good
yeah i mean um
so you'll be very familiar with this and
uh you know i think most people who
browse twitter are familiar with this
sort of thing because it happens so
commonly online um last time i was on
your show we spoke of libs of tick tock
and
i mean that that since we've last spoke
that's
exploded it's now massive you know
and um
one of the reasons it's it's massive is
that it engages in this nut-picking
which people love people love to see not
picking and that's why it's so popular
um you just you know i was browsing
through the lips of tik-tok feed the
other day it was just
seeing all these crazy people you know
that were just sort of
trying to get sort of four or
five-year-olds to come out you know the
closet and stuff and
you know i thought
if you if you spend your life following
this account
you're gonna think that this stuff is
happening literally everywhere you're
gonna think that this is extremely
common that it's like you know happening
in every school that there's a massive
plot to sort of sexualize young children
and it would drive you absolutely crazy
it would if i if i believed that the
world
you know was like a big conspiracy just
basically fill
classrooms up with these kind of
sort of sex positivity activists who are
just basically trying to sexualize young
children i would drive me absolutely
insane um and you see it you see people
online who actually believe this is
happening you know
they believe that there's a massive
operation uh to sort of
you know just completely just uh
sort of
turn kids degenerate basically
but then you've also got the left wing
version of this um which is right-wing
watch
this is a is
that what is that yeah so that's a
twitter account which is the sort of
left-wing equivalent of what do they
post
so they just post crazy like christian
conservatives you know who believe that
the the modern world is going to burn in
hellfire and all this kind of stuff and
just and mental like racists and like
you know white nationalists and stuff
like that just the craziest loons from
the right wing basically and um you know
people who are like want to blow up
buildings and just just get crazy people
on there
um and i mean if i was you know
following this account if i was
following right wing watch i would get
this idea that the right are just gonna
like you know kill everybody shoot
everybody to death with their guns and
um just basically
you know put minorities into
concentration camps or whatever so you
know that's the problem with when you
take the worst examples from each side
and then you create like a twitter feed
of nothing but those because this goes
back to what we were talking about
earlier about you know how social media
misrepresents world syndrome yeah yeah
with the meanwhile syndrome yeah um you
know all you see if all you see is just
the most extreme examples of
any
world view you're going to think that
that worldview is an existential threat
to to the world basically and that's
going to drive you crazy and it's going
to make you more extreme in your beliefs
so the long-term effect of this is that
it makes everybody more extreme which
makes it quite dangerous it it might be
entertaining you know not picking is
always quite entertaining if especially
if you're a culture warrior you know and
you want to you want to laugh at the
other side
then if you know if i was a right-winger
i wanted to laugh at the other side i'd
just go on libs and tick tock and just
uh start browsing and you know i could
spend hours on it look at a ton of the
right wing channels and and the content
that they put out i mean matt walsh from
the daily wire has um his five headlines
i would i would guess that
at least two to three news stories per
week on this show that has a big
research team probably comes from libs
of tick tock so you go okay
that's not even one um
ideology that's not even one type of
talking point that's one account
that is filtering some of this stuff
through and
one of the weirdest things about this is
it should enrage
people of the side that this account is
putting stuff out from more than it
enrages the other side yeah
should piss off the moderate left
significantly more than it pisses off
the right and it it's it feels like a
duty of the people on that side of the
fence to call out the lunatics of their
own side because they're misrepresenting
a view that you that they're taking to
the sort of caricature nth degree of
ridiculousness of you that you're
supposed to care about
people on the right they don't give a
[ __ ] they're not bothered they're happy
for you to lose yourself in pink head
walkery and the people on the left don't
care about the gun-toting christian
everyone's going to go to hell people
right they don't mind so it's your job
to be the media to not be the mediator
to be like the enforcer to bring them
back into the conversation
yeah absolutely i completely agree with
what you're saying i mean
you know i'm not i'm no longer like i
don't consider myself left or right but
i was a leftist for like 10 years
and during that time
i even when i was a leftist i was more
anti-woke than most right
leaning people because i understood
you've got a dog in the fight
yeah yeah i mean
because at the end of the day you know
who's really being harmed by
all this craziness this work craziness
it's not people on the right they're
actually gaining support from it it's
the people on the left who are being
armed by it because this this wokeness
is an embarrassment to the left because
what it shows is that the left have um
you know they they've basically allowed
themselves to lie down and be walked all
over by these
woke ideologues and yes the work
ideologues are a minority they're a tiny
minority within the left but they do
have disproportionate influence now as a
result of the left just lying down and
letting these kind of neon head children
just walk all over them
um you know now you i mean
you see this kind of stuff you know in
academia you see
powerful people in academia who have
these kinds of views you see
powerful people who work in corporate
boardrooms who have these views you see
powerful people in hollywood who have
these views you know and
the result of i mean this is all a
result of
the left
doing nothing for a long long time and
allowing this belief to just gestate and
grow and on the right
you do have a similar thing i mean
i would say that on the right slightly
different because the crazies on the
right are
generally more concerned to the fringes
but that's not to say that there are no
crazies on the right who don't receive
mainstream support i mean i would say
that donald trump was a pretty extreme
right winger although he's not genuinely
a right winger he doesn't really have
any ideological beliefs i don't believe
but he
he he rode to power on a platform of a
pretty extreme right-wing
crap you know like with all this cueing
on nonsense and stuff like that and that
is pretty insane stuff and that guy
became president of the united states so
yeah this issue does occur on the right
as well
um
but i think
that stuff is not seen as much of a
liability to the right as weaknesses to
the left because
wokeness is a lot more visible because
it because wokeness is it controls
essentially the the
west's cultural institutions academia
the mainstream media apart from fox news
and that kind of stuff uh and
sort of
hollywood and you know even publishing
as well publishing is pretty work now as
well we saw that uh penguin random house
threatened walkout when they said that
they were going to publish jordan
peterson's second book yeah and yeah
it's
i think
wokeness is a
rallying cry
sorry wokeness is an embarrassment to
the left and a rallying cry to the right
that's the way that it's seen it's the
thing that galvanizes the right to push
back against the wildness that's coming
out of that and if you are moderately on
the left it it it should be the sort of
thing that makes you put your head in
your hands and
it's strange last time that we spoke
we came up with this idea that an absurd
ideological belief is a
show of loyalty to your side and a
threat display to the other what it
proves is that you value
the group ideology
more highly than you even value reason
itself and truth
and
that i think explains so much of this
it's like is this a show of fealty to to
your side and any
slight nuance that you show is seen as a
[ __ ] in your armor by your enemies and
a lack of commitment by your compadres
right that's that's the way that it's
viewed and it means how is someone
supposed to um defect
how do you how do you move away from
that well you're not going to be
accepted by the other side because you
still hold 80 percent of the beliefs
that they don't hold
and you're not any longer going to be
accepted by your own side because
everybody's terrified of this circular
firing squad coming and going for them
they just purely spiral their way up to
an increasingly ridiculous belief yeah
absolutely yeah i think yeah conformity
plays a huge part in in this
because when you have
pretty much entire the entirety of
western culture is in the grips of
wokeness right now
um because
you think it's that bad sorry do you
remember
it's that bad i mean
you know i don't think it's an
existential threat to the world or
anything like that but i think it's it
could be considered an existential
threat to the left as we currently
understand it
and that's where that's why i oppose
wokeness not because it's a threat to
the world but because it's in a it's a
threat to the left and even though i'm
no longer a leftist i believe that we do
need a strong left in the world because
i believe it
it stands up for things that are missing
in the right
and it provides a good and solid
powerful counterbalance to the right
successes i believe really we need a
left and a right um to sort of bounce
off each other and keep each other in
check well isn't that interesting that
your major concern about what's
happening with woke isn't the people
that don't believe in it it's the people
that almost don't believe in it it's the
people that are part of their own side
yeah yeah for sure man
it's um
i really really don't know what's going
to happen rolling the clock forward with
this i do think that the tide is turning
against weapons though i do believe
gradually it's becoming more and more
acceptable to call out the [ __ ] on
the
sort of side you know um to talk about
these kinds of things for instance like
you know
the you know the gender wage gap um
say sort of three years ago if you
pointed out that the gender wage gap is
not actually due to discrimination
people would call you a misogynist and
that you know you'd probably get you'd
probably lose your job and stuff i mean
james damore do you remember him
he pointed out there are different
preferences that women and men on
average have different preferences due
to evolutionary roles and as a result of
that i mean that's that's that's real
science that's backed up by
a mountain of evidence but the thing is
is because he said that
um he was fired from google and that
happened in i think it was 2017 it was
either 2016 or 2017
and
now it's acceptable to sort of point out
that yes actually women and men on
average do have slight differences in
behavior and that leads to slight
differences in social outcomes you know
so it's like it's becoming more
acceptable to talk about these things so
i think that's a sign that wokeness is
gradually receding but i think it's it
still has a huge amount of power in the
cultural institutions but it's going to
take time for people to see through the
[ __ ] i think and to people to summon
the courage to actually speak out
against it
the problem that you have is this
tit-for-tat mentality the fact that as
one side does something that's
ridiculous that almost legitimates the
other side today it's kind of like a
relationship oh well
you texted your ex-boyfriend to go and
collect your shoes from his house so i'm
going to catch up with my ex-girlfriend
for a coffee oh well i'm going to go out
for drinks oh well i'm good and
there you go it just ends up justifying
increasingly uh extreme behavior on both
sides um but yeah i mean if the volume
could be turned down that would be great
it's definitely i keep talking about
this
the um ascendancy and then uh fall from
grace of woke is such a really good
example of why satire and um
comedy is useful online because
that word that entire group has been
memed out of existence by people that
are kind of funny
people that are funny have turned that
into a caricature of itself and the word
woke was a you were able to use it for
like two weeks unironically and then
after that it was just completely
co-opted by people that were using it to
mean the most extreme version of what it
didn't mean
yeah
yeah it's a sad thing it's like a kind
of
concept creep um but in it sort of in a
different way i suppose the opposite of
concept creep really in which the
meaning becomes more specific and very
more tailored towards a very specific
sort of world view yeah okay right next
one uh the lesser minds problem we
dismiss those we disagree with is stupid
insane or evil because it saves us from
having to deal with the complex truth
that people see things differently from
us largely because the labyrinth of
experience has led them to different
conclusions
yeah i mean so this
sort of goes back to what i was saying
earlier about munitionism
we evolved to view people of other
ideological tribes as just plain wrong
basically whether by evil or insanity um
you know 10 years ago you know when i
was a leftist i got all my news from the
new york times and the guardian
which taught me that right-wingers were
only right-wing because they were
selfish or bigoted
but then i actually got to know a few
right-wingers
and i began to see that there's a kind
of there is a value in right-wing
politics
that isn't really mentioned in the new
york times or in the guardian
um
what is that what's the value
oh there's plenty of value to it but
it's something this is something that i
learned is that
the value of leftism is very obvious and
it's very clear and it's very
shallow in a way and that's why young
people always begin as leftists
um but then
they gradually move rightwards as they
get older and the reason for that i
think
is that people become more risk-averse
because when you're young
you know you you're experimental or
you're exploratory because you've got
nothing to lose so you take big risks
and you take big chances and so you want
to completely overturn society you want
to completely change everything you know
tear down the old statues let's erect
something new you're very ambitious when
you're young but then as you begin to
accumulate things in life as you begin
to accumulate a family and a house and
wealth you become more risk-averse um
because you realize that you've got
something to lose now and you realize
how good you've actually got it you
realize how grateful
you should be because of the position
the unique position that you occupy in
history
and you realize that the things that you
thought were useless in the world
actually have a very
uh important purpose
you know this is the whole chesterton's
fence argument
and as a result of all of this you
become conservative you begin to see
things from a more conservative point of
view you realize that hang on a second
we've got it good you know you we've got
it really good to live
when we live in this time
having you know been through all the
things that our uh species has been
through
to actually live in a time where we have
all these freedoms that we you know we
don't take these things for granted
anymore because we become grateful for
them and we understand
what we have and so i think that's part
of the the value of right of the right
but there are other values as well
obviously you know like there's the more
libertarian angle where you know you
value freedom and things like that but
for me you know i i wasn't really aware
of of what i was talking about i wasn't
aware of that
until
in my sort of uh mid-20s when i kind of
like believed that
when i stopped getting all my news from
the new york times and the guardian and
sort of liberal media you know
washington post and all that kind of
stuff and i actually started to
uh talk to actual right wingers and
actually have a civil conversation with
them
and so that was when i stopped
realizing that i was sorry that was when
i realized that um
that right wingers are not evil not
simply evil or not simply stupid or or
whatever you know and
that was a big revelation for me because
it that was one of the reasons why i
started having doubts about the left
because
for the very same reason i believe that
the left were good i believed when i was
young you know i believed um the left
one they were compassionate because they
wanted an equal world they wanted to
look after everybody is that what you
mean when you say that it's obvious and
shallow
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's the the
the appeal of leftism is very easy to
see
because
who doesn't want a more compassionate
world you know who doesn't want a world
where the the weakest amongst us are
taken care of by the strongest it's a
very beautiful image isn't it um where
we all look after each other and you
know where nobody goes hungry nobody is
discriminated against it's a beautiful
image and anybody can relate to it
pretty much so yeah the value of leftism
is very clear but
be in being clear it's also quite
shallow because when you get older you
realize that it's not actually very easy
to create that world because you have to
sacrifice a lot of things to create that
world and the sacrifices that you make
can actually make things a lot worse for
everybody
and so you gradually learn about
economics and you learn about
evolutionary psychology and you learn
about all these things that the left
doesn't teach you about
and
that's when you start to have the doubts
about the left and that's when i started
having doubts and that's when i realized
i couldn't really consider myself to be
a leftist anymore because
i mean part of it was i just didn't want
to be tribal anymore you know i wanted
to see things from outside the
perspective of a tribe so i had to
abolish all
allegiances to tribes but secondly i
thought that the left itself
i do value the left i think it's
important to have the left as a as a
sort of political force in the world but
i don't want to be part of it because i
believe
that doing so would make me irrational
because i'd have to believe things about
the world that
i naturally do not
um you know i would have to dispute some
of my own
deepest convictions and so
um
yeah it's a complicated i think it's
very complicated as you get older you
realize that people have good reasons
for believing things that seem on
you know on the surface to be completely
crazy do you know so over time um age
tends to cause people to lean more to
the right
do you know if it causes people to go
from authoritarian to libertarian as
well
i have no idea about that i'd be really
interested in finding out
that no i mean one thing i've seen
research
which shows that there is a very real
trend towards
conservatism but
i don't think that there's any
particular correlation between
authoritarianism uh libertarianism
interesting yeah i just wondered whether
or not
people increasingly
uh kind of see the fallibility of
politics as they get older and you know
if you're going further down it just
means basically leave me alone
um the more that you go toward that
libertarian thing okay right um
i want to talk about the word [ __ ]
what have you learned about the word
[ __ ] recently
okay so
i was
doing a bit of research into
why things become offensive because it
just became curious to me i wanted to
know why are some things offensive and
other things not offensive
and i began to sort of think about the
word [ __ ]
and
this is a word that's quite offensive i
mean most people would consider it
pretty offensive you know especially in
polite society i mean there are a lot of
people who use it in jest but but
there's a lot of people who find it
offensive and um
you know if you ask these people why
they find it offensive and they'll say
oh it's because you know
it was historically used to refer to
mentally disabled people
which i think is a perfectly reasonable
explanation
but
then you ask these same people
do they find the word idiot offensive or
the word imbecile offensive or the word
[ __ ] offensive or the word [ __ ]
offensive
and
most people don't find these words
offensive i mean a few people find
credit inoffensive but most people don't
find idiot or embassy or [ __ ]
particularly offensive you know they use
it's very these are common words
but the thing is if you look at the
history of these words
they were also used
to refer to mentally disabled people
that's their origins their origins is
actually they were used as
categorizations of mentally disabled
people
and i i point out this example of um
the queen's first cousins um who were
officially diagnosed
as imbeciles
and as a result of that the royal family
um
faked their deaths and basically locked
them away in a care home
for the rest of their lives um and they
were and when they died
the royal family didn't even attend
their funeral
you know it was pretty tragic story but
like um it goes to show that you know
the word embassy was used even for
members of the royal family if they had
if they were mentally disabled
and so
there's this weird sort of disparity
between the word [ __ ] and the other
words which mean exactly the same thing
but which are not offensive and you've
got to ask yourself what's the purpose
for this why is the word [ __ ]
offensive but all these other words
which were used again for exactly the
same reason why they're not offensive
and i i was looking into the history of
these words and the only conclusion that
i could come to was that
it was a purely arbitrary decision so a
group of people you know a group of
intellectuals one day decided that the
word was offensive and
they
said as much to the people and you know
them i don't know where where it was
officially established but gradually
it became offensive to use that word
and so
we chose we we all collectively decided
to have a specific emotional reaction to
a certain word but not to other words
with the same meaning
and that strikes me as very strange
because
it means that a lot of the outrages a
lot of things are outrageous
are purely arbitrary they're just
they're just arbitrarily chosen
you know there's no real reason why we
should be
upset or offended by a certain word we
just choose to be offended by it
and we choose to not be offended by
other words you know so
this i think is a it was a big insight
for me because it really opened my eyes
to
exactly what outrage is a lot of outrage
is just manufactured it's purely
manufactured you don't need to be angry
about any of the things and you know or
at least most of the things that you
you're angry about you know in in
everyday life
they're not rooted in anything more
solid
than simply people making choices in the
past you also use that example of
uh is it the naacp
oh right yeah yeah i mean yeah so this
is another thing that i've never
understood
is that somehow the word colored people
became offensive and you had to use the
word the the term people of colour
instead
i've never understood why i've never
really understood why i mean i did ask
somebody who was pretty sort of woke and
they said to me
that it's because when you use the word
when you use colored people you're
you're centering color but when you use
people of color you're centering people
because the first word is people rather
than color
and so
that's a [ __ ] tenuous very tenuous
exactly i don't understand it you know
and
i have no problem with people calling me
a colored person i don't find it
effective what's your heritage
indian yep
yeah i'm indian punjabi so
i i don't have any problem with with
people calling me a colored person you
know and i don't think most colored
people do
i don't think most of us do have a
problem with it but what's really
interesting is the naacp is the national
association for the advancement of
colored people is that right yeah so
what that's like is kind of like a
fossilized record of what linguistic
territory used to be acceptable and
because they haven't updated their
branding to move in line with lexically
what's now part of the green light red
light system
yeah they're they're kind of this
fossilized record of oh
that used to be okay
but now it's not so if there was the n
double a rp
right for [ __ ] people
you go okay well hang on
is that a pejorative are you using that
to to refer to this entire what about
the cretins in the room and what about
the morons in the room what about them
where are they so yeah it's so that
the thing is is that linguistic all this
kind of linguistic
re
re-tribalizing of territory
is that it just creates outrages
where outrages don't need to exist we've
already got enough things to be outraged
about in this world plenty of things to
be outraged about in this world you know
if you you've just got to switch on the
news to see what's going on you know
in some parts of the world
but
the thing is is that uh instead of like
trying to do something about the things
that outrageous the things that we
should be outraged about some of the
injustices that are occurring for
instance you know the concentration
camps in china for instance um instead
we just
sort of kind of redraw the territory of
language and create new outrages out of
it out of nothing
we create new outrages out nothing
and
it just doesn't make any sense to me i
just don't understand why why people
would choose to be upset
over you know the the use of words is
that a little bit of so many other
things to be outrageous say is law
coming back in again the fact that you
can
create outrage and posture the fact that
you are
helping that this is something that
you're really bothered about but you
know that by pushing back against
colored people or the word [ __ ] that
really the battlefront that you're
playing on has pretty low stakes yeah
well the thing is is that if you're a
member of an ideology and you're
dedicated to a certain cause then you
have an invested interest in making that
cause seem like a bigger issue than it
actually is
so if you're an anti-racist then you
have a vested interest in making racism
seem bigger than it actually is because
that makes your task and your job and
your mission
more important than it actually is and
that's why i think a lot of
people who are sort of these who define
themselves as anti-racists
will constantly cause
they'll constantly create new forms of
racism
because they need it you know i think
somebody's said i've forgotten who it
was that they said that the
the demand for racism exceeds the supply
you know
and um
that's basically what's causing a lot of
this kind of it's driving a lot of this
these new
outrages and these new offenses because
people need
racism in order to feel like they've got
something to fight against and if you
look at you know yes
if you look statistically there there
does seem to be some
racial disparities but those racial
disparities
are not as big as they're portrayed in
the mainstream media
and the mainstream media exaggerates
these because it needs to feel like
there's a big struggle that it's
fighting against
um and so that's i think probably the
explanation for why
the word
colored people is now offensive because
we need more and more things to be
racist so that we can feel more
anti-racist when we fight against them
okay iron law of oligarchy all
organizations of people no matter how
democratic and egalitarian will
eventually be controlled by a dominant
few since if everyone has power then no
one has power and if someone has power
they'll use it to get more power
yeah so
um
so in order to be able to move an
organization forward
there needs to be a power differential
between people
it's simply not practical to have every
decision made by committee
but if someone has got power if they've
got an extra little extra bit of power
then that power will compound over time
this occurs like largely as a result of
the matthew effect
i think i've i might have spoken about
the matthew effect on the last podcast i
can't remember but um yeah the matthew
effect is the idea that advantage begets
advantage so it's sort of usually
encapsulated in saying the rich get
richer and the poor get poorer
um you know if somebody has influence
over decisions
then they can use that influence
to steer decisions that favor them and
give them even more influence
and the typical result of the matthew
effect is
is a pareto
distribution and this is basically a
sort of statistical distribution in
which you have a small number of people
holding the vast majority of power
best way to sort of really describe it
um
so the interesting thing about this
concept
is
that it can be used to justify
left-wing or right-wing politics
for the right it's a key reason for why
communism and socialism don't work
and for the left it's an argument for
regulation against monopoly power
so what you really think like what you
conclude from this
concept really depends on your your
political views but i think that it's a
very interesting
concept because
it's so fundamental because
people are always
trying to create sort of egalitarian
democratic systems or
highly competitive systems
and
this law essentially refutes the
possibility of that
i don't think it's impossible to create
a completely democratic or competitive
situation in which there are equal
players operating against each other or
with each other
but i think it's very very difficult
because like i said you need to have
some people have power over others in
order to for the organization to be able
to do anything because some people make
you could you just you just can't make
a
organization by committee it doesn't
work
even communist states
like the soviet union didn't have pure
committees they had to have
people like stalin and beria you know
who actually made decisions um
unanimously sort of thing on
unilaterally rather
um and so yeah this is that it's it's
interesting because it
it really does make you question the
possibility of
a lot of these programs that people try
to create
noble cause corruption the greatest
evils come not from people seeking to do
bad but people seeking to do good and
believing the ends justify the means
ironically few things legitimize the
immoral treatment of others more than
the belief that you're more moral than
them
yeah so once again this harks back to
what i was saying about monitionism
uh we're evolutionary configured to view
ourselves as good in our appearance as a
and our and our opponents as evil in
order to justify competing
um in order to justify conquering them
sorry so there's a weird irony in that
our belief that we are good can make us
act with great evil
what this means is that the real problem
is not that some of us are good and some
of us are evil but that we all believe
we're good and that our opponents are
evil
and if you look at history
you know the greatest injustices were
committed in the name of justice uh even
the holocaust was regarded as a means to
a righteous end you know it was viewed
as necessary to save western
civilization
um western european civilization you
know the the jews were regarded as evil
which made it easy for the nazis to
commit evil against them
i think this is
why we should
the people we should fear the most are
not simple psychopaths
but rather those with noble aims who are
convinced that they're on the right side
of history
because such people's belief in their
own goodness is so great that it can be
used to justify any evil
there's a lot more conviction that comes
from someone that believes that they're
right and knows that they're doing wrong
it's got to be more fragile you know
it's got to be more hit hit it enough
times and it's going to break if someone
is kind of laughing or they're playing a
persona or whatever versus someone who
actually genuinely believes that they're
on the side of righteousness i mean this
is the sort of crusader
style
adherence that you have to particular
viewpoints i mean look at you know after
this uvalde school shooting you know the
degree of
uh
vitriol and how vehement second
amendment um people have become online
even just buddies of mine like friends
of mine from texas that are really
really they're even
more
unprepared to give ground no like that
they're not going to give a single inch
with regards to that because
that's their
that's one of the deities that they they
hold up
yeah i think
when you're convinced that you're right
you're capable of of
essentially anything and that's the
danger because
you know even i mean if you look at
what does evil really you know
what does evil really achieve what does
somebody who's evil really do in the in
the world they usually end up becoming
serial killers um
but when you look at what
good
does in the world it leads to
genocides and massacres because people
actually believe that they're making the
world a better place presumably it's
more compelling as well like we were
saying earlier on getting people to
believe in your cause
is it's sort of a solo man operation if
you're doing something that's evil but
if you can convince someone that what
you're doing is good that's how you end
up with entire armies and nation states
behind exactly yeah exactly yeah so
that's a crucial part of it as well is
that you can get people on side much
easier because there are a lot more
people who want to do good in the world
than there are people who want to do
evil i mean there are very few people
who actually wake up in the morning and
rub their hands together and say oh
what's the nastiest thing i can do today
you know
most people want to do good but it's
just that they're misguided about what
good actually is isn't that what
peterson keeps on bringing up about how
um if you were a
german in
1941 and you were in the army you would
have been a nazi as well and everybody
likes to think of themselves as the
person that would have not sent the jews
to the gas chambers and so on and so
forth but yeah if you're convinced of an
ideology if you're convinced that these
are the people that are causing the
world to be
bad and terrible and taking everything
away from you and a threat to the the
safety of your community
that's going to compel you to do some
pretty wild things without any belief
that you're doing anything wrong
yeah absolutely i mean if you if you
actually look at
some of the interviews of um
former nazi ss guards and people like
that
a lot of them will say that they
believed that they were doing the right
thing you know when when they were when
they were carrying out their actions
they would say that they were basically
taught that the jews had um essentially
brought germany to its knees
and that they were essentially sort of
they were corrupting the entirety of
western civilization and that they were
basically like a cancer and they had to
be removed in order to preserve
everything that their ancestors that the
german ancestors had built
and um
i mean you know this is in an age where
there was no internet there was no
wikipedia you couldn't just go online
and fact check things you know so you
had to make do with the propaganda
basically that was being pushed out by
the newspapers gerbils was a master
propagandist one of the greatest
propagandists in history in terms of the
skill that he he had
and he managed to convince so many
german people that
that essentially that jews were not
human beings essentially that they were
they were
demonic beings that they're demonic
creatures that needed to be removed from
the world in order to
create a utopia in order to create a
world where everybody loves everyone and
everything is beautiful you know
and so these people were fighting for
beauty that's that's the horrific thing
about it
you know the the most ugliest things in
history were fought in the name of
beauty
and
that i think is a very
sort of striking thing a very dangerous
thing because
it's something that people don't think
much about people tend to have this
this view that
the world's evils are caused by people
trying to do evil but that's just not
the case you know very very little evil
in the world is actually caused by
people actively trying to do evil the
vast majority of injustice in the world
is a result of people trying to do good
fire hosing with so many competing
narratives in the digital age
disinformation agents can't convince you
of any single narrative so instead they
overwhelm you with many contradictory
narratives until you start to doubt
everything and become confused
demoralized and passive is this a case
where
um
sort of beating people down with an
overwhelm of information means that
they're more malleable
a little bit further down the line
yeah i mean
i first encountered this idea
when i was reading the work of hannah
arendt
who's a writer who was sort of working
in the sort of 60s and 70s
and um she had this really good quote in
fact let me uh let me bring up the quote
so i can just read it out
so she wrote um
so she wrote if everybody always lies to
you
the consequence is not that you believe
the lies but rather that nobody believes
anything any longer
and the people that no longer can
believe anything cannot make up its mind
it is deprived not only of its capacity
to act but also of its capacity to think
and to judge
and with such a people you can then do
what you please
and she wrote that
in 1978
so she was a pretty sort of good profit
because what she said has become far
more relevant in today's age than it was
even in her age you know it's been 45
years since she wrote those words nearly
45 years
and
now it's the basis for disinformation
strategies um of the major world powers
i mean you know you'll know about the
sort of the so-called gerosimov doctrine
i mean the guy who invented that term
doesn't like to use it but it's the name
is still used it um more so mundanely
known as hybrid warfare and it's this
idea you know by
developed um by garasimoth who was this
sort of russian strategist
that the best way to assault the west
would be to
create this kind of decentralized
multi-pronged attack
uh known as a sort of multi-vector
attack strategy which is basically where
you
just bombard the enemy with with very
just
so much information and so many other
things basically just overload the enemy
with with content
which will just confuse them and
distract them and just create a kind of
ideological chaos
in them and they'll make them unsure
they'll no longer know what they stand
for you know amid the fog they'll lose
track of who they are and
as a result they'll become very as you
said malleable they'll become very easy
to control they'll sort of
become easy to manipulate towards
whatever ends you want and we saw
evidence of this particularly sort of
around 2016 2017
with the firstly with the interference
in the
election and also with
the the facebook
posts by russian troll farms in which
they
they actually funded black lives matter
campaigns and they funded neo-nazi
campaigns
um and you you've got to ask yourself
why would they fund these two completely
opposing groups
and the reason is obviously they wanted
to create this kind of confusion and
this conflict you know they wanted to
sort of
bombard people with so much of these
competing ideologies that they sort of
begin to doubt their own beliefs and
they begin to wonder what's true and
what's not true
and that's really the only strategy that
disinformation can
really
fulfill in in this world that we're in
because we live in a world with so much
information you can't possibly convince
someone of a single narrative with
disinformation anymore in goebbels time
with the nazis it was very easy because
there was only one source of information
which was the nazi party um so you could
just put out newspapers with one
narrative and people would believe it or
they'd believe nothing
but
in today's age there's just so many
competing narratives it's just simply
not possible to
make anyone believe any single thing so
that the only alternative is just to
confuse people
the beautiful mess effect we tend to
view our mistakes and vulnerabilities
with shame because we think they make us
look unappealing but research suggests
our mistakes and vulnerabilities
actually make us more relatable and
endearing to other people so don't be
afraid to be human
yeah so um
there's a pressure on people to appear
infallible
to never admit when they're wrong to
never apologize
because these things are considered a
sign of weakness by society you know
um
but when you try to appear infallible
when you actually try to do that
it makes you more fallible because you
become unwilling to correct your own
mistakes
and that's why i like the beautiful mess
effect because it's
it suggests that trying to appear
infallible is not just a bad
decision-making strategy but it's also a
bad social strategy
no matter how you may try to appear to
people
they'll always know that you're just a
human
so instead of putting up this facade of
trying to be a superhero
you know an illusion that's doomed to
crumble in the end
it's much better to just be who you are
to own your flaws and mistakes and wear
them proudly as armor
so that they can never be used against
you
have you seen the recent brendan shawb
fallout from a podcast that he did
i i read something very very briefly
about it on twitter and this is hot [ __ ]
in the podcast world right yeah so i've
heard about it i don't know much about
it though yeah so him and uh the guys
from tiger belly had this big falling
out that's another podcast and then
everyone was upset about things that
brandon had been accused of doing and
what i was really interested in was
trying to work out the synthesis of why
brendan is so
disliked by a very very passionate group
of people online the uh the fighter and
the kid subreddit
it has maybe 70 000 people in it now and
it's
exclusively there to rip on them right
that's their subreddit and it is more
passionate than any supporting group
i've ever seen
and they're there to take the piss out
of people and i was really really trying
to work out what it is about brendan
beyond you know
personal preferences about delivery and
personality and stuff like that and i i
kind of settled on the fact that he is
very unprepared to show genuine
vulnerability and the beautiful mass
effect is kind of
um what's being pulled out he has this
quite sort of strong guy and again you
know he used to be a fighter he used to
be in
a professional or semi-professional
football player when he was in college
and now he's doing comedy and he's
around alpha males and he's got this
sense that he needs to live up to and
he's a dad business owner and all this
stuff
but
i think what you see is
um you're right inevitably everybody
knows that you have vulnerability behind
there
uh unless you're an absolute extreme
like a david goggins or a joker willing
or somebody like that um and even with
them i think that they're very sort of
prepared to show their own failings in
the past and this is the trajectory that
they're on to now and now you can't hurt
me and you need radical responsibility
and stuff like that
and i think that the problem that people
have is they know
or they they have a sense that behind
the facade with brendan specifically
there's something sort of soft and
smooshy and if they just keep on tapping
away that they're going to cause that to
open up but you can get out ahead
of that narrative pretty easily um you
know think about some of the most moving
podcasts that people have done it's when
they show genuine vulnerability not in a
performative way not in a way that's
done for effect almost in a
reluctant way
you know that they're trying to tell a
story and they're putting a brave face
on and maybe that got a little tears
going or they're struggling to get
through something and their voice is
cracking but they're moving through it
i
you have to really really dislike a
person to watch that
and not think
fair play you know you
put yourself on the line this is a
really really vulnerable position that
you're in
yeah i mean
yeah cause like you know um
when it comes to some people think that
bravery for instance is not being afraid
but that's not really what bravery is
bravery is being afraid and still going
ahead and doing what you you need to do
despite being afraid and i think that
that's a crucial part of this i think
that
everybody's going to know that you're a
human you know no matter what you do no
matter how many
um things you try to
how many masks you try to wear
people are going to see through them
you know they're always going to
understand that you're a human that you
have flaws so the best thing to do is
just to embrace that and to realize that
hang on a second
you're not going to convince people that
you're you know there's some sort of god
or superhero or whatever i know a lot of
people try to do that online especially
like they want to create this kind of
facade of them always being right about
things but really nobody is right about
everything everybody gets things wrong a
lot of the time and the difference
between the people who get things right
a little bit and people who get things
right a lot is that the people who get
things right a lot are willing to learn
from their mistakes but in order to
learn from your mistakes you got to
first admit that you were wrong
so
in order to be right you have to first
be wrong you know and this is something
that i think people need to do more
often because you see on social media
people are not willing to own up to
their mistakes so many times i engage
people in a debate and then i point out
when they've got something wrong and
they won't admit even though the
evidence is there right in front of them
in their own statements you know where
they've contradicted themselves or where
you know
something they've said about something
has just turned out to be factually
incorrect
um they won't admit it because their
egos won't let them and this is why one
of my
tweets recent tweets is i said that
the greatest enemy of truth is ego
because
when you are so invested in yourself
you become less invested in the world in
objective reality you become objective
you become
invested in subjective reality rather
than objective reality
and that's always perilous because
subjective reality is not real it's an
illusion so you're investing in an
illusion
whereas if you invest in the actual
objective reality the objective reality
that you are going to be wrong
that's the only way that you can really
improve yourself because that's the real
world that's the only thing that's real
the signal it gives to everybody else as
well is that you're a
you're a good player in the game
yeah it's worth their time investing in
you
because you're not an immovable object
that perhaps if they were to convince
you of something then maybe you'll
change your mind and that means well
i'll actually invest in this yeah
absolutely i think if you want to
convince people
then the best way to do that is to show
them that you can be convinced
because it shows that you're a
reasonable person that you will listen
to reason
and that is i think it gives people
faith in you whereas if you you know are
sort of like a kind of
nicholas nasim to leb kind of character
you know it doesn't matter how
intelligent you are if you're just kind
of like no i'm right i'm always right
i'm never wrong you know then people are
going to lose faith in you even if you
are always right they're going to lose
faith in you because that confidence i
think over the long term it begins to
great on people and they don't people
don't like arrogance
and
they sense it in people if you you know
if you constantly if you never admit
when you're wrong if you if you know if
you never admit when you're human
people are going to see straight through
and i think that's what probably
happened with brendan schaub is that he
um
you know he does seem to be
somebody who's quite fake
and because i've seen him on joe rogan
and when he's on joe rogan he's very
different to how he is when he's on the
fire in the kid you know when he's with
them uh brian um forgotten surname but
yeah cullen that's one yeah
and um i think people see that they see
that it's just a facade that he's put up
in order to protect
some kind of vulnerability that he has
you know and they're gonna keep tapping
away they're gonna keep on going okay
and that's what they do yeah yeah don't
don't try and
open that wound but if you were if i was
to give him advice
uh on how to kind of deal with the
current milieu that he's swimming
through i actually think that it's so
far gone now that there isn't really
much turning around but if i was to give
him advice i would say look man you need
to take a little bit of time off from
the show you need to genuinely do some
reflection and you need to come back
within a 30 minute long monologue that
explains to people about exactly why
you've been the way you are that says
look
this is the kind of perspective i have
this is the world view i have this is
why the sort of
actions that you've seen have been
portrayed in the way that they that i've
been doing them
uh and
even the most hard-nosed bastard
would
as long as you can convince people that
that's genuinely the truth and that's
the sort of um wolf in sheep's clothing
problem that you get with performative
vulnerability that when you end up
trying to fix the problem with genuine
vulnerability people say no we we know
that this isn't the truth but you have
to be a pretty hard-nosed bastard to
look at somebody do that
genuinely open up and go
no i just still don't believe you
it's really difficult look man dude i uh
i appreciate the [ __ ] out of you um the
stuff that you put out online is
fantastic you've got
sub stack now as well yeah where can
people get your sub stack yeah it's a
goinder.substance.com so that's g u r w
i n d e r dot sub stack dot com
and
g underscore s underscore
b h o g a l on twitter at twitter
actually not actually to know sorry just
it's a it's at g underscore s underscore
b-h-o-g-a-l
that's my twitter handle get another
thread done i want to do another one of
these as soon as possible i will do nice
one i appreciate you thanks man yeah you
too thanks chris what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you